the gyro can experience the difference
between a $500 watch and a $5,000 watch
and a $50,000 watch and a $500,000 watch
it's just further and further into the
details that one watch that was good for
400 years that's it man yes there's and
there's other ones like that I have a
hard time with that yeah I'm having a
crazy math machines I love I love the
crazy math machines there's watches at
play chimes there's watches that where
you you you hit a button and like a
thing like dances like a cuckoo clock
there's like all kinds of crazy people
don't kill us
yeah there's a genre of porno watches
we've seen the porno watches where it's
literally you hit a button and people
like start banging like on the yeah no
yeah no no what's a mechanical
animatronic cumple starts [ __ ] on the
dial
oh well that's it's kind of hilarious
thank you but it's an entire genre of
watching their very very expensive very
hard to google that what's that one I
saw this one guy had one that was like a
dome and inside his own a planet yeah
yeah that's called the Jacob astronomy
ax and so any member who wears that like
you got the yeah there are a million
dollars you gotta be some kind of pimp a
planetarium ah yeah remember Jacob the
jeweler that's him this is us this is
the universe you can't wear one of those
and have people look at you without you
be you're being a little crazy so the
astronomy it's it's like a fishbowl you
put on your [ __ ] wrist it's the
weirdest thing ever
and it's designed so that's the
mechanism that rotates around the
fishbowl and it's got something called
the thing that's flipping about is
called at or beyond and that is the time
regulating mechanism and the mainspring
which keeps it wound and then as you can
see that the actual clock itself rotates
and stays vertical and then you've got
this earth thing and then you've got
this this big diamond that's been around
and it's it's a huge thing you wearing
your wrist it's probably 48 or 49
millimeters and it's it's like putting a
fishbowl on your wrist because it's got
a big glass like case over it
so cool so that's yeah that's what one
looks like in person that is so crazy
look at this a million dollars so this
one is showing is the roulette wheel one
no it's got a roulette wheel in it that
actually works
oh my you wind it up and it sends a ball
and you actually can play roulette on
the watch that's it's called the
Astronomy a casino yeah batshit right
imagine you lose your house now look
this one's an animated one it's an oil
derrick that pumps home so when they
spin it like I'm sure he'll show it but
look yeah the oil do so did somebody
design this because they owned an oil
company certain that that is what I had
it made yeah oh my god that's amazing
yeah how much you think it cost me it's
probably million dollars it is yeah it's
gross - it wouldn't want touch no it's
not cause you don't want to wear
something like that no it's like why are
you getting it that's crazy I don't know
why I wouldn't get it but like if you I
don't know why you'd get it you have to
really appreciate the art of it look I'm
just going down there there oh it's a
hoot man floating it's cool I mean that
you know there's another company called
M B and F which is not as kind of dumb
for lack of a better word it's less just
a little less flashy and it looks like a
[ __ ] rocket tear Trekkie space
communicator but it's all mechanical
it's called MB and ampersand
F and they come out like people are
doing some real creative [ __ ] Joe oh
they really are like that's the kind of
[ __ ] that made 10 Kaczynski move to the
woods we've done the Unabomber I knew
where all this is going these people
can't leave anything alone they have to
innovate on everything okay what's
really okay is that it's look it makes
our life way more interesting but
there's worse things than innovating in
a mechanical timepiece oh no it's
amazing so that's this is M BNF this is
where these those two domes sort of spin
around they make a couple different like
crazy one but god that's beautiful yeah
so they have these sort of real spacy
kind of alien device type watches there
I mean they're very expensive but
they're very nice for teachers let me
see that again
that's so pretty the one with the four
is really crazy too
why is that yeah just so you can see on
the left is the hour and the right is
the minute that's like a scale the whole
time a scale at Grandpa's house that one
this is my jam that's this that's the
Space Jam right there is that it's just
crazy [ __ ] watchmaking dude here's
that yeah it's back that up the one what
is that what's of that one V that you
see the bottom left I have a phone if
you want to know the time yeah this [ __ ]
ain't for telling the time bro this is
for telling everybody that you run [ __ ]
that is the craziest thing to have on
your body right got a house on your body
so in this one this one the entire clock
moves around the diamond course it does
you know why wouldn't it why wouldn't it
of course it does spin [ __ ] I mean you
know it's it's all real crazy the round
one is very clean that was that the
concentric one yeah as the clocks that
looks like a UFO that one the right-hand
side that you just had that you just had
Jamie what is that this no no the one
the blue ones are blue one that you just
had
yeah that's concentric rings is that
it's the rings are concentric so you see
the line on the bottom so it's 552 is
the time there or 452 excuse me for the
center's no squirrel in the center is
the tour beyond that's the mechanism
that powers it there's other watches
have you ever heard of an h YT watch no
h YT watches are [ __ ] nuts because
they are lik they're powered by bellows
and liquid so they tell the time yeah
give me one where you can see some of
the liquids so much I don't study this
[ __ ] wait now that's not a good picture
j1 I want to show the liquid
specifically so that one right there
that yeah we did so yeah yeah so the
liquid fills up and moves around the
face as the time goes and these bellows
move so you see the bellows in the
middle there it's pumping the liquid
around the [ __ ] copy like you've
shown that maybe before I'm familiar
with us yeah yeah the liquid one so
those are like 40 50 60 thousand dollars
to get such getting real crazy pollution
that's such crazy ballin that's called
72 G's that's call ones pretty goddamn
dope
Rose is sponsored by this company horsey
its provide an angry rock-and-roll guy
perfect not saying that Axl is but you
know got angry style that's a perfect
thing all right yep
Axl Rose Taylor like you know I'm saying
I know some people couldn't like takes a
certain type yeah but if you wanted to
get into some really next-level
weirdness that's a good that's a good
way to do what is that what's that be a
ps/2 risk drive scubapro that's a that's
a dive computer Oh
scuba diving computer oh yeah that's
that that one right there is another DNF
legacy machine perpetual so this round
one right one to the right Jamie that I
think makes me feel the same as reverse
Alex Honnold
that's what diving I feel to say I'm
like yeah yeah this one does the are the
same [ __ ] as the first one I showed you
it counts the date and stuff for like
four hundred years but it just does it
in a prettier crazier way oh my god
that's so beautiful
yeah that's see this is what I'm
fascinated by that somebody and some
group of people obviously saw one wizard
and they're doing it at multiple
companies all around the world yeah and
they're innovating and they're competing
with each other to make cooler and
weirder [ __ ] yeah and all this stuff is
like I guess it's a watch but it's way
more than just a white like that thing
up sorry Jamie go back to that one that
was that weird
spaceship one that was yeah the the one
right there right there right there that
one let space communicator why that is
so crazy yeah that thing yeah that's not
really a watch this one's cool it's
mechanical but it's it's but you read it
from the side like that it's very very
space communicator yeah it's cool
it's something different it's I mean
what it's like it's like the night it's
like that singer DLS right they take
this old the old way and they evolved
the old way as far as they can so these
waters have this amazing materials like
really interesting alloys they make for
stuff they a lot of these companies make
their own alloys which is really
interesting look at this thing what is
that it's like a it looks like what we
thought a spaceship was going to look
like in the 1950s
geez yeah and it's a watch yeah doesn't
that kind of looks at its Howard yeah
it's like moving The Rocketeer it
reminds me of the rocketeers rocket yes
yes yes it's totally like it's yeah like
you know how Ellen's only seen space
balls like this dude's only seen The
Rocketeer that's so beautiful
yeah so this it's incredible dude and
you if you most people will think you're
a weirdo for wearing it but if you wore
something like this to like a watch
nerds gathering Oh Mike don't think
you're the king of the universe you walk
in something this is going to a watch
nerd gather there's a grand psycho party
they announced the new watch oh there's
the guys I'll watch it Godzilla watch I
don't really like car watch Co brands I
think the connection is obvious enough
you don't need to shove it in my face
hmm but I'm still gonna go to the party
it's a car watch Cobra Godzilla is the
Nissan GTR not the movie monster so it's
a cross branding with the Nissan GTR and
I got confused I thought it was like an
anniversary thing for Godzilla I think
it's the Nissan GTR oh so that Godzilla
that Godzilla oh well it looks dope it
does look tough oh wait it might
actually be the movie Godzilla at the
anniversary maybe it is this [ __ ]
64th anniversary they came out with GTR
watch like months ago so maybe I just
know news you you did I remember the GTR
watch was like a chronograph yeah yes
like a bunch of different well yeah
that's what I get for not this is doing
my homework I guess it is the movie
monster anniversary my bad
it looks like it's uh like a dinosaur
skin yeah the leather skin yeah there's
see that one that you see our 50th that
was like a couple months ago so sorry
they're manufacturing they're finished
quality is amazing let me see that
Godzilla thing again did you do the
thing I told you about the reflections
on the back of the hands not yet so
grand Seiko leave it there finishing on
the back of the hands as good as the
finishing on the front of the hands and
if you reflect a light certainly certain
ways you can get it to reflect on the
dial it's really cool the thing looks
wicked yeah they make it nice watch well
they have really pretty design and
whoever is designing their stuff it's
very that's a weird thing about like
watch is there anything that someone
makes it's like what what appeals to the
I like that that TGT studio
clock see that thing right aside like
that's awesome yeah it's something it
appeals to the eye it's an piece of art
that also tells you the time but there's
something about it like the way it's
shaped the way it's formed yeah it makes
you want to look at it it's answers well
the really the very best watches
yeah just stare you just stare at them
sometimes like your watch I love is your
Spring Drive yes yeah so the Spring
Drive with the super standing I mean you
don't know where it'd be diving - we're
done you know [ __ ] hits the fan I want a
waterproof watch no you just get you get
your [ __ ] wet all the time probably
right between the tanks and the sweating
and the washing your hands and whatever
it's definitely gonna get wet
occasionally yeah I mean it's a dive
watch isn't for people who dive it's for
people who just get their hands wet tell
it to it diver they want to piss in your
mouth right now
[ __ ] you bro I'm a diver I'm a scuba
diving instructor are you really yeah
you teach people like I can I did in my
early 20s well then you get how I do
this
what's uh it's gave me a diver pass yeah
all right I'm good
Shazam i absolve you
[Applause]